could be a foul on a jumper
Steve Kerr wanted to travel here on
melot first finish her story yeah so he
wanted number seven and so Donnie Walsh
who was a team at the time calls me into
his office and he's like Carmela was
telling us he wants your number I'm like
well he's gonna have to give me
something he's got to pay me something
right the guy was like well you guys
just yeah and figure out the number so
I'm like okay cool so Carmelo comes in
there I say what's up to him I'm like
bro let me hold something come up off
that paper I know you're paid he's like
don't worry I got you I start to throw
out a number he doesn't let me get it
out he's like I got you don't worry
about it so I'm thinking you know what
I've seen people pay people for a jersey
numbers hit the hundred thousand I'm
thinking 20 racks minimum and my boys
are hyping me up and I walk in the next
day he hands me a check for $3,000
that was it I almost walked up to him
before the game I was like girl can I
get an extra 10 G's that Jersey moving
now Caleta I mean no calligraphy classes
could you've made a three into a thirty
it got me any paid by check yeah you've
made by check the problem is I don't
have any leverage with the team I wasn't
a sorry if I was a star I could have
been like nothing less than fifty racks
I'm not coming off this number seven but
I didn't have that leverage I was heard
I didn't get to play he knew that and he
had all the power I blamed my boys for
my high expectations cuz they got in my
head they were like bro
this dude is super paid you gotta hit
him over the head with nothing less than
a hundred K I'm like you're right
indeed that when Carmelo stops you you
shouldn't stage with the number